[Musik]
5:30 Uhr Stoßzeit in der Backstube
Traublinger
die Ware muss raus in die 25 Münchner
Filialen Heinrich Traublinger führt
seine Bäckerei bereits in der vierten
Generation die steigenden Energiekosten
machen dem Bäckermeister schwer zu
schaffen wenn wir den Strompreis nehmen
und wir haben bis jetzt noch keinen
Deckel sind wir mindestens mindestens
bei dem achtfachen von den Stromkosten
das heißt wir haben eine Kosten Tsunami
ein Kosten Tsunami der alle erfasst in
ganz Deutschland demonstrieren in diesem
Herbst tausende für mehr Lohn
alles ganze Lebenshaltungskosten hat
sich für zweifach verdreifacht Gaspreise
Öl selbst Ölheizung
gehen nach oben und im Geldbeutel bleibt
nichts hängen ich bin 42 ich kenne sowas
situation ne und das machen wir auch
gewaltig Angst Angst vor einer
ungewissen Zukunft ein Gefühl das
Beschäftigte und Unternehmen eint denn
der Standort Deutschland steht unter
Druck
wir sind aktuell besonders gefordert
durch diese hohen Energiepreise eine
historische Inflation und zu geringes
Wachstum bedrohen Europas führende
Wirtschaftsmacht das lässt sie natürlich
nachdenken wollen sie noch in
Deutschland investieren wo sie nicht
wissen wie ihre Zukunft aussieht
Sanktionen gasmangel Angst vor dem
Blackout
all das bedeutet dass wir uns
tatsächlich in einer kriegsähnlichen
Situation befinden
es ist ein Stresstest für den Standort
Deutschland
ein Test der mit dem täglichen Brot
beginnt
Bäckermeister Heinrich Traublinger
kämpft mit einem achtmal höheren
Strompreis
zu glauben dass das Bäckerhandwerk über
alle Produkte
gleichermaßen diese Kostensteigerungen
die wir ja haben weitergeben kann ist
ein absoluter druckschloss wir können
hier nur ein Bruchteil der Kosten der
weitergeben und selbst das ist für
manchen Kunden einfach zu viel das
erlebt seine Ehefrau Annemarie jeden Tag
als verkaufsmanagerin der Bäckerei steht
sie oft auch selbst hinter dem Tresen
die Menschen sagt sie kauften heute
anders ein als vor der Krise es hat sich
verändert dass die Leute nachdenken was
Sie brauchen und was sie kaufen weniger
spontan Käufe finde ich und wir haben
auch Kunden die Fragen vor sich kaufen
nach dem Preisen und schauen wirklich
die Preisschilder an und müssen dann
manches liegen lassen schon ein paar
Cent mehr fürs Brötchen oder das Stück
Kuchen machen sich im Portemonnaie
bemerkbar
dann macht es zehn Euro 75 bitte spürt
man überall also beim Bäcker überall
spürt man das dass die Preise drauf sind
selbst beim Katzenstreu wir haben im
Monat zur Verfügung und dann muss man
jetzt ja schon die letzte Zeit ein
bisschen was drauflegen ja
etwas einschenken es geht nicht mehr so
dass
man das kaufen
dass die Menschen nicht mehr so viel
einkaufen ist eine Folge der Krise wo
Filialen mieten und eine immer höhere
Energierechnung eine andere
von drastischen Maßnahmen bleibt auch
die Bäckerei Traublinger nicht verschont
wir haben Filialen geschlossen ja die wo
man sagen da rentiert sich das immer
wenn man Verhältnis Miete zum Umsatz
sieht und es waren wirklich Filialen
also das Stammhaus war schon Opa und Oma
hatten haben wir mit schweren Herzens
geschlossen so wie den traublingers geht
es vielen Handwerksbetrieben in
Deutschland
der Mittelstand insgesamt stellt sich
auf schwierige Zeiten ein dabei sind die
steigenden Energiekosten nur ein Problem
damit einhergehen hohe Rohstoffpreise
und ein seit Jahren bestehender
Fachkräftemangel das bedeutet aber in
einer solchen Krisensituation wie wir
sie gerade beobachten das sicherlich
einige Mittelstandsunternehmen das nicht
so gut managen werden und vielleicht
dann auch an der Stelle ihr Geschäft
aufgeben müssen die Krise erfasst auch
Weltmarktführer wie den Mittelständler
Kelheim fibers aus Niederbayern aus Holz
werden hier hoch spezialisierte
Viskosefasern hergestellt
Ausgangsprodukt für Hygieneartikel oder
Teebeutel alles biologisch abbaubar doch
dafür braucht es Energie viel Energie in
Form von Gas das kostet die hohen
Gaspreise für die Geschäftsleitung von
Kelheimer schon lange das bestimmende
Thema
Krisensitzungen sind an der Tagesordnung
ja die Gaspreis hat sich hier vor
15-facht ist es etwas was man noch nie
gesehen haben die jetzige Situation ist
sehr herausfordernd am Ende wird es
definitiv
intensiv sucht das Management um Crack
Barker und Wolfgang Ott nach Wegen aus
der Krise zunächst ein Umstieg auf Erdöl
und dann sobald als möglich auf
Wasserstoff
die Kunden die sind ruhig stehen aber
auch selbst und der Preisdruck und es
ist momentan so wir brauchen definitiv
in den nächsten drei bis vier Jahren
Überbrückungshilfen manche sind schon
genannt wurden die Kunden allein werden
es nicht Schulden können
sollten die Energiepreise so bleiben
rechnet der
bundesarbeitgeberverband Chemie damit
das rund 20% der mittelständischen
Unternehmen von der Pleite bedroht sind
als Vorsitzende des Sachverständigenrats
Wirtschaft berät Monika Schnitzer die
Bundesregierung in ihrem aktuellen
Gutachten hat sie die Schwächen der
deutschen Wirtschaft genau analysiert
wir haben uns in unserem Gutachten
angeschaut wen das besonders trifft das
heißt wer arbeitet besonders
energieintensiv wir haben im Branchen
identifiziert für die das möglicherweise
schwierig wird das ist die
Metallerzeugung Glaskeramik das sind
bestimmte
Grundstoffe in der chemischen Industrie
da könnte es schwierig werden noch
stehen internationale Kunden wie Procter
und Gamble zu kelheimers doch der
Betriebsrat ist längst alarmiert schon
fürchten viele der 750 Mitarbeitenden um
ihren Job
das Problem ist wir agieren am Weltmarkt
und am Weltmarkt ist es nicht überall so
wie in Europa also wir müssen schauen
dass man wieder mithalten können
das ist jetzt wieder Populismus oder
Stammtisch Gerede man muss der Industrie
mittlerweile muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
die Stimmung an die Leute haben vorher
verängstigt und werden jetzt sage jetzt
mal es kommt richtig aggressiv und
letzter Zeit für in einem sind sich
Geschäftsführung und Betriebsrat längst
einig die Zeit drängt und eines wird
auch hier ganz deutlich viele
Mitarbeiter kämpfen schon jetzt mit der
Krise
fordert einfach ich habe hausbaut wir
haben neue Kredit abzahlen und das Gold
reicht halt zurzeit schon ganz knapp
also das ist echt schwierig
der Wocheneinkauf ich bin zum Einkauf AG
ich habe früher zwischen 150 Euro zahlt
für ein Wocheneinkauf mittlerweile bin
ich da schon eher über 200 bis 250 Euro
das Geld es ist immer weniger wert
Anfang des Jahres stand die Inflation in
Deutschland noch bei 4,9 %. und stieg
zum Herbst hin auf einen Rekordwert von
über 10%. gleichzeitig dank der real
Lohn also das was nach der Inflation
übrig bleibt
was das für das Einkaufen für den Konsum
in Deutschland bedeutet weiß er ganz
genau Rolf Birkel konsumexperte des
Marktforschungsunternehmens GfK
Inflationsraten von über 10%, das gab es
in Deutschland zuletzt in den 50er
Jahren Großteil der Bevölkerung hat nie
Erfahrungen gemacht mit der
atominationsraten das sorgt natürlich
für enorme Verunsicherung für sorgen vor
allem die Haushalte die keine Rücklagen
bilden konnten oder keine Rücklagen
gebildet haben die müssen jetzt
plötzlich deutlich mehr für Energie aber
auch für Lebensmittel bezahlen auf die
man nicht so ohne weiteres verzichten
kann bereits 60% der deutschen Schränken
sich beim Einkauf mittlerweile ein so
eine Umfrage des Deutschen
handelsverbands
was es heißt wenn Kunden wegbleiben
erlebt sie jeden Tag Romana schems
kleiner Delikatessenladen in der
Altstadt von Nürnberg bleibt oft leer
die seltenen Gewürze edlen Lebensmittel
oder Schokoladen finden kaum Abnehmer
man hat aber gesehen dass dass diese
Leute die unterwegs waren das sehr
wenige mit Einkaufstaschen unterwegs
waren und auch wenn ich mich mit meinen
Kollegen unterhalte die sagen alle ja es
war eine Menge Leute in der Stadt es war
viel los aber es Kaufverhalten war nicht
so wie sonst wo der Tourist doch immer
gern das ein oder andere noch mitnimmt
der Umsatz ihres Ladens ist in diesem
Jahr wie bei vielen Einzelhändlern um 30
bis 40% zurückgegangen
ob Romana schem ihren Lebenstraum weiter
halten kann entscheidet sich Ende des
Jahres wir sind Gott sei Dank in der
Lage dass der Laden schuldenfrei ist im
Moment halte ich es noch durch
ich werde mir am Silvester überlegen wie
ich in die Zukunft gehe
Romana schems Geschichte ist die vieler
Ladenbesitzer es sind diese
Einzelhändler an denen sich auch das
Schicksal der Standorts Deutschland
entscheidet der Konsum spielt ja eine
wichtige Rolle für die Konjunktur für
die Entwicklung der Konjunktur in
Deutschland mehr als die Hälfte des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes ist private
Konsum das heißt also es wird ganz
entscheidend auch davon abhängen wie
sich die deutsche Wirtschaft auch
mittelfristig entwickelt das auch der
Konsum wieder in ruhige und und stabile
Bahnen Gerät dafür arbeitet auch
Alexander Schramm jeden Tag der
Berufskraftfahrer ist nördlich von
Frankfurt unterwegs auf seiner täglichen
Tour zu den Supermärkten der Region
Schramm liefert die Lebensmittel die wir
jeden Tag brauchen
Lkw-Fahrer wie er werden händeringend
gesucht in diesen Tagen im täglichen
Straßenverkehr spürt er diese
Wertschätzung kaum
keiner weiß wie wichtig eigentlich
dieser Beruf hier ist und sehr oft wird
sich nur über uns aufgeregt weil wir
sehr langsam auf den Straßen unterwegs
sind weil die LKWs das meistens mit dem
Gewicht auch nicht so schnell können
Alexander Schramm fährt für die
Spedition Meyer Logistik im hessischen
Friedrichsdorf
2017 hat das Unternehmen begonnen einen
Teil seiner LKW-Flotte auf Biogas
umzustellen um die CO2 Bilanz zu
verbessern eine Investition die die
Firma heute in Schwierigkeiten bringt
das sind natürlich sehr kritisch jetzt
durch die ukraine-krise hat sich der
Gaspreis in den letzten Monaten über
siebenfache verteuert die Fahrzeuge sind
wenn wir keine Kunden haben die das
mittragen nicht mehr gesellschaftlich
einsetzbar so dass es dazu führen kann
dass wir Fahrzeuge in die Ecke stellen
müssen still legen müssen das
Familienunternehmen beschäftigt 2500
Mitarbeiter an fünf europäischen
Standorten durch die corona-krise sei
man mit einem blauen Auge gekommen
erinnert sich der Chef nun aber Seemann
eine Kosten Welle auf sich zu rollen das
Speditionen wie seine am Markt bleiben
darauf sind Supermärkte in ganz
Deutschland angewiesen systemrelevant
ist ein Wort was ich vorher schon mal
gehört hatte aber was noch nie so eine
Bedeutung bei uns gefunden hat wir
wurden in der corona-zeitung auch jetzt
sind wir systemrelevante wenn seine LKW
nicht fahren bleiben die Regale in den
Supermärkten leer
wie lange können Sie wenn das jetzt so
weitergeht eigentlich noch so
weitermachen wie bisher nicht mehr lange
das Jahr läuft alles andere Büro sich
und wir stellen die Weichen für nächstes
Jahr und wie genau diese Fragestellung
und die sind damit verbunden wie machen
wir im nächsten Jahr weiter werde ich
genauso weitermachen wie dieses letzten
Jahr oder die letzten Jahrzehnte nein
das können wir nicht wir müssen uns
übertriebener Maße ein Stück neu
erfinden wir sind insofern in einer ganz
neuen Situation als wir dauerhaft mit
höheren Energiepreisen rechnen müssen
also über die nächsten zwei Jahre werden
die Energiepreise wieder sinken aber
nicht auf das alte Niveau von vor dem
Krieg
der Standort Deutschland ist im
Stresstest es handelt sich nicht um eine
Krise Deutschland kämpft mit mehreren
Krisen gleichzeitig
erst der corona-lockdown mit
Absatzproblemen und gebrochenen
Lieferketten
[Musik]
jetzt explodierende Energiepreise
steigende Inflation und sinkender Umsatz
die lechstahlwerke bei Augsburg hier
entsteht über eine Million Tonnen
Qualitätsstahl im Jahr im März nur zwei
Wochen nach Beginn des Ukraine Kriegs
blieben manche Öfen kalt als erste
Stahlwerk in Deutschland mussten die
lechstahlwerke auf die steigenden Preise
reagieren schon damals schlug das
Management Alarm
mit solchen Energiepreisen arbeitet man
nicht wirtschaftlich bei weitem nicht
das können sich vorstellen die
lechstahlwerke sind Bayerns größter
Recyclingbetrieb der Stahl hier wird aus
Metallschrott gewonnen der zum Beispiel
bei der Müllverbrennung anfällt vor
allem die Autoindustrie und der
Maschinenbau setzen auf diesen
nachhaltigen Werkstoff
gewindeststahl von hier ist auch im
neuen One World Trade Center in New York
verbaut made in Germany rund um den
Globus für seine Produktion aber
benötigt der Stahlwerk den Strom von
300.000 Haushalten in der
Geschäftsleitung sieht man schwere
Zeiten auf das Unternehmen zukommen
wenn Sie nun sehen dass die Stromkosten
innerhalb von zwei Jahren um den Faktor
10 gestiegen sind dann bedeutet das dass
unsere Stromrechnung rechnerisch von 40
Millionen auf 400 Millionen Euro
ansteigen wir verlieren unsere Fähigkeit
die hohen Energiekosten waren schon vor
der ukraine-krise ein gravierender
Standort Nachteil für die deutsche
Stahlindustrie damals lagen die etwa
doppelt so hoch wie zum Beispiel in den
USA
im Vergleich zum Jahresbeginn 2021 ist
der Gaspreis für Industriebetriebe um
über 450% gestiegen der Preis für Strom
um über 330%
. den lechstahlwerken geht es nicht um
billige Energie egal woher sie kommt
auch hier hatte man die Zukunft längst
mit Erneuerbaren geplant etwa
Wasserstoff und Solarenergie
die Frage die sich in der Branche
derzeit viele Stellen ist aber eine
grundsätzliche
das lässt sie natürlich nachdenken
wollen sie noch in Deutschland
investieren wo sie nicht wissen wie ihre
Zukunft aussieht oder wollen sie in den
USA gehen wo sind Zehntel der
Energiekosten haben also die Gefahr dass
wir die deutsche Stahlindustrie
verlieren ist da
verliert der Standort Deutschland einen
traditionellen Teil seiner Wirtschaft
wird Deutschland ein Land ohne Industrie
der internationale renommierte
Wirtschaftshistoriker einem TuS spricht
das aus was in deutschen Ohren fast und
denkbar klingt man sollte auch nicht vor
dem Begriff der den des Realisierung
zurückschrecken dass das in diesem Sinne
passt sich Deutschland eigentlich nur an
das an die gewöhnliche
entwicklungsfahrt der von anderen
reichen Ländern an das heißt weniger
Jobs wie wir sie bislang kennen die
Arbeit wird digitaler Mitarbeitende
müssen ein Berufsleben lang dazu lernen
was vermutlich bleiben sie die
Kompetenzen also die hochqualitativen
Arbeitskräfte die ausgebildeten
Ingenieure die gesellschaftliche Ordnung
all das ist
krisenbeständig und auch erlaubt
Deutschland auch mit Krisen umzugehen
eine Industrie die sich nicht verändert
könnte bald der Vergangenheit angehören
die über 800 Mitarbeiter der
lechstahlwerke sehen in eine ungewisse
Zukunft die Stahlfabrik ist ein
bedeutender Wirtschaftsfaktor der Region
gerät sie in Schieflage trifft das viele
kleine Unternehmen
die die ganzen kleinen Firmen
Auswirkungen
das ist alles weg in Augsburg
dementsprechend große Industrien die wo
alle Energie mit dran sind du hast in
Gersthofen ist die Chemieindustrie mit
dabei die waren Gas hängt also wie soll
es funktionieren irgendwann ist es am
Schluss wenn wir fallen fällt der
restautomatisch die lechstahlwerke sind
auch ein Traditionsbetrieb für viele
Familien gleich mehrere Generationen
haben hier gearbeitet oder tun dies noch
immer so wie die Brüder Helmut und
Manuel Schapers mein Bruder arbeitet
hier unser Vater ist seit 72 hier soweit
schon angefangen dazu zu produzieren und
wir waren mal ganz viele mittlerweile zu
zweit da war ich ja mal sein Meister er
unter meiner Fittiche sie dann auch
wieder hochgearbeitet eine Stufe
weitergekommen im Endeffekt und zwar
muss ich sagen hat sich das entwickelt
nur das ist bei uns irgendwie Tradition
seit 72 war immer irgendjemand von
unserer Familie in diese Firma und da
hängt dann natürlich schon viel Herzblut
auch dran
und auch die junge Familie von Manuel
schablers vor zehn Jahren hat sie sich
ein Reihenhaus in der Nähe des
Stahlwerks gekauft schon während Corona
mussten sie mehr für Energie bezahlen
der Grund Homeschooling die jährlichen
Kosten von 1.200 Euro haben sich jetzt
verdreifacht
klar mit drei Kinder sind die
Grundkosten an sich schon mal relativ
hoch
Essen wird immer teurer wir haben jetzt
indem ihr angefangen viel selbst
anzubauen im Sommer also
Gemüsepflanzen Tomaten Gurken
ja und um da die Kosten etwas zu senken
einen Arbeitsplatz bei den
lechstahlwerken hat man sein ganzes
Leben in diesem Glauben ist Manuel
schablers aufgewachsen eine Gewissheit
die es heute nicht mehr gibt die Güte
von der Krise jetzt oder von dem was
hier passiert hatten wir noch nie die
Krise kostet Geld viel Geld es trifft
die Menschen auf allen Ebenen in den
Firmen genauso wie in den Familien durch
die gestiegenen Gas und Ölpreise
erleiden die Deutschen in diesem Jahr
Einkommensverluste von 64 Milliarden
Euro Geld das der Volkswirtschaft fehlt
in einer solchen Krise wird es
tatsächlich zu Anpassungen kommen manche
Unternehmen werden
schrumpfen oder sogar ganz aufgeben das
heißt die Beschäftigten da müssen neue
Anstellung finden
Deutschland im Wandel
alte Industrien und gewohnte Strukturen
verschwinden mit ihnen tausende von
Arbeitsplätzen neue Jobs sollen
entstehen indem Deutschland digitaler
moderner und nachhaltiger wirtschaftet
kein leichter Weg denn die globalen
Rahmenbedingungen ändern sich dramatisch
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
des analyseunternehmens Prognos in
München sie gehen der Frage nach wie
wird diese Welt aussehen wir haben uns
angeschaut was für Deutschland auf dem
Spiel steht wenn die Welt wirklich in
Blöcke zerfällt und die Welt wartet
nicht im Gegenteil eine neue Ordnung
könnte entstehen auch für die Wirtschaft
welchen Platz kann Deutschland darin
finden
wir befürchten jedenfalls dass die Welt
neu aufgeteilt wird im Moment zeichnet
es sich ab dass wir uns wirklich damit
auseinandersetzen müssen dass wir
dauerhaft verschiedene ökonomische
Blöcke haben es gibt mehr Konfrontation
in der Weltwirtschaft und das ist eine
Situation auf die wir uns ich fürchte
dauerhaft einstellen müssen neben Europa
zählen China und die USA zu den
wichtigsten Handelspartnern der
Bundesrepublik nach Ansicht der
Wissenschaftler ist deutschland als
Exportnation von diesen rivalisierenden
Blöcken abhängig wichtig ist dass wir
verstehen vor welcher riesigen
Herausforderung wir stehen und es
wirklich annehmen wir haben uns lange
auf Russland verlassen als
Energielieferant wir haben sehr
intensive Handelsbeziehungen mit China
wo wir viel importieren viel exportieren
all das ist jetzt ganz neu zu bewerten
und das wird uns fordern diese Realität
diese neue Realität vor der wir stehen
auch aktiv zu gestalten
die Wirtschaftsmetropole schensen im
Südosten Chinas ein Symbol für die
Wirtschaftskraft des gigantischen Landes
aus der einstigen Werkbank der Welt ist
die zweitgrößte Wirtschaftsmacht auf dem
Globus erwachsen aus dem einstigen
Partner ist ein Rivale geworden
im Kampf um die technologische
Vorherrschaft fordert China Deutschland
offen heraus
die Frage ob wir mit einem Land
Handeltreiben dürfen dass die
Menschenrechte offen missachtet und
politisch an der Seite russland steht
stellt sich nicht wir tun es längst in
nie gekanntem Ausmaß
5000 deutsche Unternehmen sind in China
tätig
europaweit betrachtet investiert
Deutschland mit 43 Prozent am meisten in
den chinesischen Markt allein die drei
Autohersteller VW Daimler und BMW sowie
der chemie-riese BASF machen 34% der
europäischen Direktinvestitionen aus
über eine Milliarde Euro setzt der
Autozulieferer Webasto mit seinen elf
Standorten in China um
der Hersteller von Schiebedächern
Abdeckungen oder Batterie Packs macht
dort rund ein Drittel seines Umsatzes
im Gegensatz zu anderen Firmenchefs ist
Holger Engelmann bereit offen über das
China Geschäft zu sprechen ein Rückzug
aus dem chinesischen Markt für Engelmann
nicht denkbar mit China oder ohne China
mit Kindern weil wir einfach eine
Weltwirtschaft haben und wir nicht 1,3
Milliarden Menschen
ignorieren können gerade als eine
exportorientierte Nation
wir können nicht hier auf Block fahren
wir müssen eine Möglichkeit finden auch
mit einer Region China mit einem Land
China
zu kooperieren auszukommen warum China
nicht nur als Exportmarkt kaum
verzichtbar ist zeigt eine Studie von 46
Rohstoffen die Deutschland für
strategisch wichtig erachtet müssen 39
importiert werden viele davon aus China
ohne diese Importe kann der
technologische Wandel in Deutschland
nicht vollzogen werden
bestimmte Dinge kann man gar nicht nur
von den Freunden beziehen das ist
insbesondere bei kritischen Rohstoffen
der Fall die werden eben zum Teil in
Ländern abgebaut und sind nur dafür
verfügbar die wir jetzt nicht
notwendigerweise als lupenreine
Demokratien bezeichnen würden es ist ein
Abhängigkeitsverhältnis aus dem sich
Deutschland alleine kaum befreien kann
die einzige Möglichkeit für Deutschland
dieses Verhältnis in irgendeiner Weise
auszugleichen ist gerade nicht als
Deutschland gegenüber China aufzutreten
sondern als Teil der EU als Teil des
europäischen Verbundes denn Europa
insgesamt ist für China selbst für China
eine strategische relevante Größe die
Frage der Abhängigkeit beschäftigt auch
die Chefetagen besonders in der
Autoindustrie seit corona-krise und
Ukraine Krieg ist diese Frage lauter
geworden
unterbrochene Lieferketten und
Produktionsstopps haben sich in den
Bilanzen bemerkbar gemacht und
eingebrannt in die Köpfe der Vorstand
der Blick nach China ist jetzt
nüchterner wir sind konsequenter bei den
Lieferketten dass wir noch konsequenter
versuchen sie zu trennen regional zu
trennen oder so mindestens jede
Komponente die über einen Ozean geht
analysieren wir wirklich ist es
notwendig heißt aber mehr mehr Aktivität
in den anderen heißt aber nicht eine
gebremste Aktivität in China die
deutsche Wirtschaft denkt also neu
darüber nach wo sie künftig mehr
investiert Fabriken baut Menschen
beschäftigt kurz wo Wertschöpfung
stattfinden soll dabei geht der Blick
nun auch Richtung Westen Beispiel USA in
South Carolina investiert BMW 1,7
Milliarden Euro in den Bau neuer
Elektroautos allein 700 Millionen in
eine neue Batterie Fabrik
die Politik in Amerika legt sich mächtig
ins Zeug klatscht begeistert Beifall
deutsche Firmen sind hier hoch
willkommen der Senator von South
Carolina Lindsay Graham feiert das BMW
Investment im Oktober 2022
möge Gott BMW weiterhin segnen
nicht nur BMW viele Konzerne planen ihre
Investitionen in den USA massiv
auszuweiten darunter Lufthansa Aldi oder
Siemens
der Maschinenbauer ebm-papst aus
Baden-Württemberg möchte vor allem bei
seinen amerikanischen Kunden sein und
lange Lieferketten vermeiden doch auch
andere Standortfaktoren sprechen für
Amerika
haben wir Unsicherheiten wegen der
syrovik-politik der Regierung in Amerika
haben wir stabiles Umfeld Arbeitskräfte
sind vorhanden stabile Energieversorgung
und vor allen Dingen der Markt der Markt
wächst mit der Attraktivität der USA
wächst die Gefahr dass der Standort
Deutschland zunehmend in Frage gestellt
wird
made in Germany ein Auslaufmodell
es gehört nicht zur Natur der Dinge das
hundertetausende von Menschen in
Deutschland ihren Brot durch Autobau
verdienen tausende von Menschen arbeiten
im Handwerk wie Bäckermeister
Traublinger der Druck auch hier immens
das Bäckerhandwerk wird sich aufgrund
dieser Krise verändern wie das weiß man
bis jetzt noch nicht
traditionelle Unternehmen stehen
endgültig auf dem Prüfstand mit ihnen
die Menschen die dort arbeiten
es gibt eine wirklichen Ausblick wo was
hin läuft oder hingeht also die
Unsicherheit ist doch sehr groß
Deutschland wird auch künftig
exportieren aber werden es noch
dieselben Produkte sein
[Musik]
schön wenn wir weiter Autos und
Maschinen verkaufen wir sollten aber
nicht darauf wetten dass es in diesem
Maße so weitergeht wie in der
Vergangenheit
Deutschland steht vor grundlegenden
Änderungen
wir müssen tatsächlich die notwendigen
Strukturreformen ganz entschieden
angehen das ist die Ansage in der
aktuellen Krise es ist ein Stresstest
für den Standort Deutschland
[Musik]